how's it going Rossum through that my
name is pinned back and now yeah we're
gonna play Library of Alexandria today I
don't know the story about that old
librarian or I can try but I guess
pretty good I guess I could be prayed
again yes as always start my videos for
the loading screen cuz I'm too lazy to
edit out stuff
I mean wari mañana
[ __ ] it's so slow just because I said it
not responding is it was great started
great start oh there we go I'm pub oh
barrels
uh I've been walking these corridors for
days
when shall I arrive hi hi where I don't
know you there buddy
my colleague mr. Walker has begun the
excavation without me I fear that he is
desperate native help okay that would
make sense
I can an idea what is talking about mr.
Walker I'm here
well God open up Oh better sorry I'm
doing my own version
oh look at the house look at this
I can't go there sad face Oh someone
made a mess and leave me looking at maps
is too much
alright signing up Rick
Oh what's going on here July 17 truly a
marvelous place first ride almost every
paddled like by the rock and fan you've
taken some time I used a 2x2 pedal a BRE
can't wait for a about learning clover
season but tolling and there yeah might
seem pretty good story Oh
so this says
yeah yeah
yeah
Wow
oh man this is awesome
yes finally you can pick these up it's
so stupid ID game aah aah oh man is
still dark though
it's upstairs or downstairs I'm going
it's so hard to tell oh oh hello hello
well guys it yo sorry hello oh [ __ ]
Oh
ah
it's not funny Walker nah huh not funny
not fooling anyone I write rap uh-huh
stop doing that I don't even know what
is this I got a great staff don't [ __ ]
with me I got a great staff okay
actually I don't know what I do with
this the tablet is the solar system it
appears to be two orbits the primary
secondary with the primary being closest
to the Sun
okay so that's puzzle that Apollo but I
miss my book actually no my [ __ ] not
scare me like that okay what is this the
Sun is the center of everything
good [ __ ] thing I lost my flame
anything me what is this anyway
finally later August trendy how Oxford
cloak man again he told me two great
things a stone to stone this down this
down oh that I want to meet that guy he
seems like a pretty cool guy okay
are you gonna walk past these
here and here we have Mars this lesser
so I would assume these are the planet
yeah shame
this could be the buyers what is this
what is this ha
the primaries in it is own Eclipse Venus
invert secondary canary canary I put
this here
oh look at that I got one maybe you go
here nope dead nothing
that's turn into something else
what about this
and the moon is like here now what that
do I win
nope I didn't win but I know this is one
is correct
cuz it's glowing and [ __ ]
I have to find all of these holy [ __ ] no
way no way I can find all of them
Mars is lesser is less me I mean I know
what light series stuff like beneath the
boxes somehow got a do this we gotta do
it for science
are you already saving there it is yeah
I don't think it's that obvious I know
Oh [ __ ] think it's that obvious
where's the phone although [ __ ] that
some [ __ ] no Stefano really really right
okay
- or breeze the primary secondary
uh-huh
I guess I'd just have to solve the
puzzle
[ __ ] I can't solve this puzzle it's
impossible
so that was incorrect
I was incorrect to mashite okay after
not cheating or anything don't suspect
me cheating I think this is here and I
think this is here and I think this is
here do I win
where's my cookie give me my cookie yes
I get cookies horny high fiving pass
around we're sorry
like I'm not sorry you better enjoy my
singing badge
oh man look at the time it's so late how
long did I stay up last night that's
all right
all right let's try this oh it never
works anymore it was so awesome
can't they open these apparently
up
what do you want me to do it's raining I
don't want to go outside
Wow hi oh there's nothing
see what this does
hello did nothing you did nothing
this is obnoxious clock
yep we have nothing
come on MSS beautiful
I don't know what you're there wow so
handsome I wish I'd had his beard so
beautiful
oh I'm a genius haha my genius
I threw it this window oh [ __ ] you
actually work I thought I threw it out a
window I thought okay maybe I didn't
throw it out the window
bah ah shouldn't it just jump out I
should have thought about that for a
couple more seconds I think
man eludes the police
no newspaper kills me wait I was
supposed to die are you kidding me I
don't even like it this come on
mushrooms they're soaked ah
mushrooms what is this
salvia
it's all beautiful
I agree with you I like the [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that you measure or think that is
Walker how the [ __ ] the gate is open ah
and the evil for us right should I send
you our guys I did nothing
turn shall consume baby na na
a star's fire and disease shall become
blood happy righteous shall fall before
the wicked and all creation shall
tremble before the burning a siren sir
yeah whoa what the [ __ ] did you just
fall come push me oh I don't like being
Falcon barn I just so got see no problem
evil shall blah blah blah
no problem really okay problem maybe
maybe a little part had to leave this
place but I just entered OH
good job opening the gate over evil and
then you're going on oh oh oh the [ __ ]
ah nice monster nice monster
I don't want anything I just want to get
out of here what oh oh oh no no it's
just what the way okay
oh you can do this Petey you can [ __ ]
do this
oh man this is not my good face right
now this is my um [ __ ] scared face oh
hello
nope nope nope no I think I'll go rear
nicely I love to come to your tea party
um maybe
oh oh oh [ __ ] there's totally something
there oh [ __ ] fetus
oh okay very good we're good
he doesn't see me even though he's right
[ __ ] there
I'm not scared I'm just gonna go over
here yeah
oh man oh [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] dead end
unless this is fun isak yep
I'm screwed I never been this screw to
might highlight oh okay it's tears
[ __ ] love stairs all that sergers
awesome okay
stop breathing so freaking loud okay
stairs are awesome
ah you have got a people oh no I don't
want to go back there please
oh okay let's just take it slowly oh
maybe there's more doors stone here
oh come on okay we can go here well I
doesn't seem very nice though but
whatever it has naked guys it's kind of
cool his penis is English stomach for
some reason I know we made that but yeah
that's definitely a penis in his stomach
oh man oh freaking man ah mr. stone
don't talk to me right now I'm busy okay
okay dad another dead end
taking you with me Oh even though I
can't put
yeah apparently I really was excited to
bring
mr. sound with me but whatever [ __ ]
says you are the carrier come on
so I'm doing deaf is nah don't blame
this on me
don't so put this on me her just darling
them along the halls rabbit
I tried calling for you but he get cut
my tongue God so sorry I'm so sorry for
the safety of our world he can never
leave this place
he forced me to swallow the key to the
door bow I don't know why I'm afraid I I
love you of it but I love you Robert so
we touch his stuff and we get maybe the
key you like that you like that you like
when I touch your penis oh wait there's
one there too I think he prefers this
you like that huh you like that number
Susie Robert stopped rolling
oh [ __ ] huh I gotcha
hi frickin gotcha oh we're back here
this is freakin ghost is in here don't
Gary I don't like that mom why what do
you want from me this was let's do this
buddy I know you like me I know you here
yes come here you little aah aah I'm
sorry bro
aah you shouldn't have scream
you shouldn't have [ __ ] scream
oh I picked up the game huh why are you
screaming brah
why you scream on me I hate screaming
okay I'm just gonna get the [ __ ] out of
this place and I'll see that [ __ ]
ghost later haha what an idiot girls all
the doors open now anyway oh man oh man
oh man oh my [ __ ] ghost man oh
all again I was Library of Alexandria
hope you enjoyed house that was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] sound Jesus Christ
ah it was more moody scary than jump
scary for once I'm used to jump scares
in nowadays but that was actually really
scary I think anyway leave a thumbs up
and I'll see you tomorrow I'm a [ __ ]
walking paradox no I'm not
threesomes with a vocal Triceratops the
Reptar rapping as a mock and deaf rock
stars - ecstatic wigs made of n wash